here's what's key in creating drama
intention and obstacle somebody wants
something something standing in their
way of getting it they want the money
they want the girl they want to get to
Philadelphia it doesn't matter but they
have to want it bad if they can meet it
uh that's even better something
formidable is standing in the way of
getting it it was a normal day like any
other day when all of a sudden the
tactics that your protagonist uses uh to
overcome the obstacle is going to Define
uh uh who the character is it's you
don't tell the audience who a character
is you show them what the character
wants uh what matters is that the
intention
be important to them that and that we
understand why it's important to them
and the obstacles have to be real